>> Carla Hayden: We're ready,
we're ready and I'm so glad
to be here on the purple stage,
I even wore my purple top.
Because this is one of
the best times to be here.
Because I am Carla Hayden,
I'm the Librarian of Congress.
And I started out.
[ Applause ]
One of the joys of being the
Librarian of Congress though is
that you get to be with authors
and people that you have admired
and have written books
and done so many things.
And this person that
I'm sitting here
with is the person
we're all here to see,
Mrs. Jacqueline Woodson.
[ Applause ]
Talk about a superstar books,
she is it and I'm just going
to read, I know you
know all of this
but I think it just
bears repeating.
That she is the 2014
National Book Award winner
for her New York Times
best selling memoir Brown
Girl Dreaming.
[ Applause ]
Which was also a recipient of
the Coretta Scott King Award,
A Newbery Honor, the NAACP
Image Award and a Sibert Honor,
all like the Olympics.
The Olympics of Young
Peoples Books in 2015,
she was named the Young
People's Poet Laureate
by the Poetry Foundation,
her recent book for adults,
Another Brooklyn was a
national book award finalist,
she has two dozen
award winning books,
she's a four time Newbery
Honor, this is like champion it,
but that's why she has a medal
because just recently she was
named The National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature
for the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
So she is an Olympic winner.
And so there are more awards
and I know you, you know all
about that but what is
really wonderful is the fact
that you have a new book that
I shared a few minutes ago
with Justice Sonia Sotomayor.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
That's so great.
>> Carla Hayden: Who said
that when she was growing
up she didn't have books
that reflected her
heritage Puerto Rican.
What about you?
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
I think the same thing,
I grew up in 70's in South
Carolina and Brooklyn
and there were very few
books that I could open up
and see someone who looked
like me, who had a family
that reflected my family.
And we talk a lot about what
Dr. Rudine Sims Bishop talks
about in terms of people
needing mirrors and windows
and sliding glass
doors in their books.
Mirror book is a book where you
see a part of yourself in it
and there weren't a lot of
mirror books in my childhood.
>> Carla Hayden: And I had that
and this was a long time ago.
A little book Bright April
and it was a little brown girl
and I loved to see, I
thought that was me.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Is
Bright April still in print?
>> Carla Hayden: It's
going to be reprinted
because I talk about it a lot.
But that meant so much to me,
I said look there's my family
or look there's that and even
when it's complicated
it was good to see.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: So true.
I remember the books for me,
the first one ever was Zeely
by Virginia Hamilton, Stevie
by John Steptoe and Roll
of Thunder, Hear My
Cry by Mildred Taylor.
>> Carla Hayden: Mildred Taylor.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: And so
you've written I mentioned one
of the books for adults, but
you really have concentrated
on books for young people.
Why did you say, you know
that's where I want to stay?
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
I love young people.
I think y'all are going
to change the world,
I know you're already
changing the world.
I think young people
are the people
who are still having
conversations,
who are still thinking about
things and still figuring
out who they're becoming and
what they're going to do.
And I write to fill the gap that
was my childhood literature.
So, so growing up and
not having the books
that reflected my
experiences I know
for a long time there
were a lot of books
that didn't reflect a lot of
experiences and I really wanted
to put those experiences into
the world and legitimize them.
But I just love, I remember
a teacher telling me
about Madelyn Engle
saying when you write,
write remembering
the child you were.
Because the essence of
childhood doesn't change,
you know the technology changes,
the fashion changes,
it changes back.
But who we all are as
young people, what we want,
that sense of belonging, that
sense that they're other people
in the world like us that
says as Matt and Lauren talked
about love, feeling
loved, being loved, loving.
All of that is the thing all of
us at some point in our lives
or at all points
in our lives want.
And it's what I write about
and what I love writing about.
And so I mean I write
because I love writing.
But I also write because
I feel like I want
to have these conversations
through literature.
>> Carla Hayden: What about
writing about feeling different,
I know I was kind of nerdy
and all kinds of other stuff
and I always felt a little odd.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yeah,
yeah definitely, I mean I grew
up in a single family,
my mom was a single mom
and then my grandma
came to live with us.
But a lot of kids had moms
and dads and I'd go to school
and the teacher would be like
well ask your mom and dad
and I'd be like well that's not
me, she's not talking to me.
And those small ways in which
I felt different, invisible,
unseen I really, I don't want
anyone to ever have to feel
that way, especially
young people.
>> Carla Hayden: And
books could help that.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Yeah definitely.
>> Carla Hayden: And
words and poetry,
now what about the poetry?
Because that's a
different way with words.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yes.
When I was growing up I
was very afraid of poetry.
I thought it was this
kind of secret language
that I wasn't meant
to understand.
And it wasn't until I
discovered Nikki Giovanni,
I remember my mom had an album
of Nikki Giovanni's poetry
and I was like what is that.
And it was kind of this ah ha
moment, then Langston Hughes,
Gwendolyn Brooks and the poets
that really began to speak to me
because I understood
what they were saying.
And because of them I was
able to eventually understand,
you know Robert Frost, EE
Cummings and all the poets
that I later got introduced to.
But as a young person I was
just like, what is that,
why are the lines
breaking like that,
what is all this white space,
why didn't that sentence end
with a period, like
all the questions
of what is this thing
called poetry
and then I figured it out.
>> Carla Hayden: And it
started to flow from you?
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yes, yes,
I mean it's our first
language right?
When babies are speaking
they speak
in these incomplete sentences
and then you fill it in.
But it's a musicality to
it, it's such a beauty
to those early words and
there's a lot of white space
around that, a lot of you
meeting the young person
and understanding them and
having the conversation
through their few words.
>> Carla Hayden: Now there
were a lot of and I know this
because I've met a
few, aspiring writers,
how many of you love
to write already?
Wow I knew that.
I knew that.
Poetry? Non-fiction?
Fiction, stories?
So you have aspiring writers
what do you advise them to do?
They're already doing it.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yes.
The way to write, the way to
learn to write is by reading.
I can't say that enough and you
don't have to read hard books,
I think reading picture books
teaches you a lot about writing.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh I
have to ask that one.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Because
from the very first line you
start getting a picture,
it's a very short story,
right when you think of
my book The Other Side,
that summer that
fence that stretched
through our town seemed bigger,
we lived in a yellow house
on one side of it, white
people lived on the other,
mamma said don't climb over
that fence when you play.
She said it wasn't safe.
So you get this whole
picture, you get the beginning
of a story, you get
some of the middle of it
and boom it's very few words but
it's, it's giving you beginning,
middle, end, it's
giving you character
and you didn't just have to
read 500 pages to learn that.
So, so I say start
with the picture books
and really study them,
read the same books
that you love again
and again and again.
If you love, if you're
writing fantasy you have
to be reading fantasy.
If you're writing poetry you
have to be reading poetry.
If you're writing
realistic fiction,
you have to be reading
realistic fiction.
And writing is a muscle, so
you have to use it every day
or else it goes soft, right it
atrophies as we say, so write,
try to write something every
day and try to read everyday
and read like the writer.
When I have a book called
American Negro Poetry Anthology
that I got from the
library when I was probably
about 12 years old and I
remember my mom taking me back
to the library when she found
it years later and making me pay
for it out of my allowance.
Out of my allowance.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
She was so mad.
And in the book there's
a Langston Hughes poem,
I Love My Friend, He
Went Away From Me.
The story ends same as it
begins, I love my friend.
And then right next to it
in my little Jacqueline Woodson
handwriting I have I love my
friend, she's gone now,
like I had copied his
poem and made it my own.
And that's how you
learn to start writing,
you learn from the writers
that came before you.
You copy their styles eventually
you find your own voice.
So young writers now
is the time right?
Share your writing
with people you trust.
If you read something to someone
and they say I don't like it,
don't ever share
it with them again.
>> Carla Hayden: Really?
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Because that's not helpful, no,
no that's destructive criticism,
that's not constructive.
Constructive criticism.
>> Carla Hayden: I like that.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Yeah, it's someone,
when I share my writing with my
friends the first thing I say
to them is, just ask me, tell
me only what you love about it,
that's all I want to hear, is
everything you love about it.
And then they tell me
all these great things
and that makes me want to
go back and write more.
And then the next time I
say ask me three questions.
Why did Jeremiah end
up at that school,
you know why did [foreign
word] parents leave Colorado?
Why did, you know why did
Clover's mother say she can't go
to the other side of that fence?
Why did Mia's family move away?
And then those questions help me
fill out the story I'm writing.
>> Carla Hayden: That's
really liberating isn't it?
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: That if
someone is that negative
when you first ask
them to help you.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Yeah goodbye.
>> Carla Hayden: Let it go.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Bye Felicia.
>> Carla Hayden: Bye Felicia.
I like that.
You can't help it.
Well now, now you mentioned
earlier the other part
of the advice is
write something,
write something everyday.
Now on my first reaction
is someone that doesn't
like to exercise and
just like exercise,
well what if you don't
feel good that day or what
if you don't wanna write or
what if you're going on a trip?
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Then read because that's.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh okay.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: If
you're reading very slowly,
if you're really studying what
you're reading, you're reading
like a writer, you're reading
as an engaged reader and this is
for teachers who are saying
finish that book in a day,
it takes writers a long
time to write those books,
so let the students
read them slowly please.
And read the same things
again and again like I said
because you're studying.
When you get to the end of
a page and you're crying
over something the author
wrote, go back and find
out what words the author used
to get you to that feeling.
The author didn't
say oh she was sad,
the author really showed you
how that persons sadness looked.
And this really teaches
you how to, how to write,
how to get to sadness, how to
have emotion in your characters.
How to have tag lines,
he said, she said.
You know when people talk
it's not like oh I went
to the store he said, like
their arms are moving,
right they're doing stuff
and studying literature
helps you do that.
And again you could
study picture books,
you could study middle
grade books,
you can study adult books.
But just read them again
and again and study them,
so if you're not writing and,
because maybe you don't
have something to write with
or you're in a car, read.
If reading in a car
makes you nauseous.
>> Carla Hayden: That
happens to people.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yeah
if it makes you nauseated
an audio book is another way
of getting to story,
my son I was talking
about my son who's a
huge Jason Reynolds fan.
That boy always has
a book in his ear
and he reads differently.
And so audio books really
help him get to comprehension.
So there's all kinds of
ways to get to books.
Audio books I don't know if you
all know this, you can get them
on your phone from your library.
>> Carla Hayden: Free.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Free
99, that's free in slang talk.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Free 99 is free.
And you know use your libraries,
I'm not saying this just
because I'm the ambassador who.
>> Carla Hayden: Or
she's sitting next to.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: I'm
saying this because I grew
up in a family that
didn't have a lot of money
and we didn't have this,
we didn't have book
festivals like this.
And if we did we wouldn't have
been able to afford the books.
So but we lived at our library
and my mother always made
sure our cards were current
and she always made sure we went
to the library and
took out books.
And that was my access to books
and by extension my access
to becoming a writer.
>> Carla Hayden: Is that
world that was open to ya.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Uh hum.
>> Carla Hayden: Now you
mentioned reading picture books
and sometimes older kids
and young people say
oh picture book, no.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: No, no.
>> Carla Hayden:
Read them, it's not.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yeah,
picture books are not just
for little kids, picture
books are for anyone
who wants a good story.
If you feel like the pictures
are too babyish just read the
words, read the words as a
poem, deconstruct the poem.
And it's a good way for teachers
to teach about poetry and again
to teach about the arc of
a narrative in 32 pages.
If you're, if you read
differently and words are hard
to come by look at the pictures,
in a good picture book you don't
even have to read the words
to know the story because
the pictures tell the story.
And so the pictures
should stand alone,
I always with young
people I'll take a book
that they haven't seen yet
and I'll show the pictures
and ask them what do you think
the story is trying to say?
What is it about?
And they'll have all
these brilliant answers
without having read the
words because they know,
they're learning how to
read through the pictures.
>> Carla Hayden: You
mentioned reading differently.
Could you expand on
that a little bit
because I think there's
more recognition now
that there are many
ways to read?
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: And
there no right ways.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Yeah there is.
>> Carla Hayden: To
read different ways.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Yeah.
I'm trying to get rid of
terms like reluctant reader,
struggling reader, people read
and they read differently.
Some people read
books really quickly,
some people read
books really slowly,
I still read books
really slowly.
I've always read books really
slowly as a result I have a lot
of comprehension, but
if the class had been,
the class would be finished the
book long before I was finished.
Both my kids the same
thing, read very slowly.
And reading slowly is not
the wrong way to read.
Taking your time to figure
out words and decode language,
it might take some
people longer than others
but that doesn't mean
they're not as bright,
it means they do
this differently.
I played basketball better
than, you know my sister.
We, but that doesn't
make me a better person,
that makes her not,
that makes her,
basketball not her sport,
it's my sport right?
But my sister read really
really quickly and I think
as a kid I was always like
well what's wrong with me,
why and for those of you who
read Brown Girl Dreaming,
you know this, my sister
was always, you know get,
they wanted to skip her, she was
always getting these accolades
as an academic.
And here I was coming along
and you know I'm reading not
up to grade level quote unquote.
I'm reading slowly,
I'm daydreaming
and basically teachers was like
well what's wrong with that one.
But what it is is once a
young persons brilliance gets
recognized and every young
person has a brilliance,
their passion is that brilliance
and that brilliance is
their passion recognized.
So for me my passion was
writing and I'm sure people are
like well how is she going
to be a writer when she's
such a slow reader and what they
missed was this is exactly how
you become a writer.
>> Carla Hayden:
Is reading slowly.
Well I wanted to ask if
you could share this.
I mentioned that Justice
Sotomayor wrote down the title
to the book and we're
going to send her a copy
because when I explained to her.
>> Jacqueline Woodson : I just
presented her with a copy.
>> Carla Hayden:
You presented her.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: I did.
>> Carla Hayden: Yes because
she was so intrigued growing up,
being Puerto Rican and when
I told her about this book
and the way it celebrates
when you begin
to celebrate being different.
It took me a lot longer and I
wish I had a book like this.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Thank you,
so I should read part of it?
>> Carla Hayden: I
think you should.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Okay.
>> Read all of it.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: I don't
think we have time to read all
of it but I can definitely read.
>> Carla Hayden: The good parts.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
The day you began.
There will be times when
you walk into a room
and no one there
is quite like you.
Maybe it will be your
skin, your clothes
or the curl of your hair.
There will be times when no one
understands the way words curl
from your mouth.
The beautiful language of
the country you left behind.
My name is Ricaberto
[assumed spelling],
we just moved her
from Venezuela.
And because they don't
understand the class will fill
with laughter until the
teacher quiets everyone.
Ricaberto from Venezuela,
your teacher says so softly
and beautifully that your
name and homelands sound
like flowers blooming, the
first bright notes of a song.
There will be time when
the words don't come,
your own voice once
huge now smaller
when the teacher asks what
did you do last summer.
Tell the class your story.
We went to France Chalay
[assumed spelling] says.
These shells came
from a beach in Maine.
A boy named Jonathan holds out
a jar filled with tiny shells
so fragile they look
like they'll turn to dust
in your own untraveled hands.
My whole family went
to India, Spain,
South Carolina each souvenir
a small triumph of a journey
that travels going on and on.
And as you stand at that,
in front of that room you can
only remember how the heat waved
as it lifted off the curb.
And your days spent at home
caring for your little sister
who made you laugh out loud and
hugged you hard at nap time.
You can only remember the
books you kept on reading long
after she had fallen to sleep.
And in that room where no
one else is quite like you,
you'll look down at
your own empty hands
and wonder what good is this
when other students were flying
and sailing and going somewhere.
There will be times when
the lunch your mother packed
for you is to strange
or to unfamiliar
for others to love as you do.
When even your own friend
Naja will wrinkle her nose
and say what is there,
what's in there anyway.
And you'll wonder how she
doesn't see the rice beneath the
meat and [foreign word].
You'll wonder why
she doesn't remember
that rice is the most
popular food in the world.
There will be times when the
climbing bars are too high,
the run is to fast and far,
the game isn't one you
can really ever play.
I don't want them on
our team, you can watch,
maybe you can have a turn later.
There will be times
when the world feels
like a place your standing
all the way outside of.
And all that stands beside
you is your own brave self,
steady as steel and ready,
even though you don't
yet know what you're ready for.
There will be times when
you walk into a room
and no one there is quite like
you until the day you begin
to share your stories.
My name is Angelina and
I spent my whole summer
with my little sister
you tell the class.
Your voice stronger than
it was a minute ago.
Reading books and
telling stories
and even though we were
right on our block it was
like we got to go everywhere.
Your name is like my
sisters, Ricaberto says,
her name is Angelina too.
And all at once in the room
where no one else is quite
like you, the world opens
itself up a little wider.
To make some space for you.
This is the day you begin
to find the places inside your
laughter and your lunches,
your books, your
travel and your stories,
where every new friend has
something a little like you.
And something else
so fabulously,
not quite like you, at all.
[ Applause ]
I read the whole thing.
>> Carla Hayden: She
read the whole thing.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
I read the whole thing.
>> Thank you.
>> Carla Hayden: Thank you.
Because when you thought about
this what were you trying to do?
Give that strength?
>> Jacqueline Woodson: I
was, the book was inspired
by a passage from Brown
Girl Dreaming where I talk
about my great great grandfather
who is the only black
kid in his class in Ohio.
In the 1920's and 30's and
growing up my mom always said
to us, you know they'll be
times when you walk into a room
where no one is like you.
And deal with it, like
what are you going to do.
And don't be afraid of it.
And I think especially in
our country at this moment
in time there's a lot of fear.
And I think there are a lot
of people walking into rooms,
young and old who
don't have a sense
that they belong in that space.
Or that they have a
right to that space.
Or that everyone else in that
space has something in common
with each other and
they're outside of that.
And so I started writing The
Day You Begin to explore that
and understand for myself first
because I always write books
so I can have a better
understanding.
And then a sense of empowerment
that, that every time we walk
into a room we're a
gift to that room right?
You know and the room should
be happy to have us in it.
So, so The Day You
Begin began from there.
>> Carla Hayden: Well
you are a gift to us.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Oh
so you are you Dr. Hayden.
>> Carla Hayden: We are so glad
that you walked up
on this stage.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Thank you.
>> Carla Hayden: So thank you.
She's going to be signing books.
She's going to be
answering questions.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Yes thank you.
>> Carla Hayden:
Thank you so much.
So let's begin to be with you.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Thank you
Dr. Hayden you're so brilliant.